hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast applications of pre
clinical translational imaging
technologies for improved modeling and
decision-making presented by Paul Mackey
Don he is a senior principal research
scientist at ad Z I am Marjorie Torres
of lab routes and I'll be your moderator
for today's event we are delighted to
bring you this educational web seminar
presented by lab routes
lab routes is the leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars before we begin I would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box that
appears on the screen will answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for at the end of the presentation if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the help
desk button located in the promotional
board at the bottom or center of the
screen or use the ask a question box to
let us know that you're having a problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the accreditation button
located in the promotional board at the
bottom or center of your screen and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Paul Mack Adan I will now turn the
presentation over to him
okay thank you very much I appreciate
the opportunity to speak at this
important conference and appreciate the
attention of the attendees today I'm
going to be talking about translational
imaging and how it impacts the drug
discovery and development pathway and
the important part that it plays in that
process certainly new drugs serving
unmet medical needs are one of the key
value drivers to research based
biopharmaceutical companies and the
efficiency of research and development
really has declined in the last several
decades so as far as the pharmaceutical
industry transitions from an era of me
to or slightly me better drugs to one of
more highly innovative medicines that
results and markedly improved health
outcomes it really has to the industry
really has to refocus its resources
which is money in town on discovery
research and early translational
medicine so here in this talk I'd like
to focus on how translational imaging
candy risk Canada drugs and impact
productivity and efficiency along that
pathway one of the most successful ways
to add efficiencies within that pathway
is then to focus on the development of
biomarkers measuring biomarkers
biomarkers are characteristics that are
objectively measured and evaluated as
indicators of normal biologic processes
disease processes and even
pharmacological responses to a
therapeutic intervention and so this
type of strategy has really been shown
to make the direct drug development
discovery pathway more efficient and so
the ability to identify molecules with
insufficient efficacy or safety issues
prior to late phase clinical development
which is the most expensive part in the
process would really reduce the cost and
increase the rate of developing new
therapeutics and it turns out that
imaging is particularly good at
identifying or measuring biomarkers so
we can use imaging to identify critical
information such as bio distribution of
the drug pharmacodynamic activity of the
drug we'll talk a little bit about that
later
again biomarkers of the actual disease
process and even use imaging to select
birth to strata stratify patients
selection for clinical trials
and so the key is here we'd like to
avoid going blindly into these expensive
clinical trials especially the late
clinical trials and to avoid this we're
applying imaging strategies for several
things and one is to define target
uptake can we identify does the molecule
actually reach the intended target in
vivo and a relevant animal model imaging
can help us guide dose selection what's
the minimum dose required to occupy the
target the safest dose but the one that
produces appropriate pharmacodynamic
activity does binding of that target
actually elicited a relevant please liya
logic or therapeutic response imaging
will help us identify safety issues are
there off target responses and again it
would definitely help patient
stratification which patients to enroll
for early clinical trials so the
overarching idea with utilizing a
biomarker approach and especially
imaging is can we predict what's going
to happen in clinical trials by building
up enough cogent preclinical data and
relevant animal models again there's a
number of ways to look at biomarkers
imaging seems to be one of the best
strategies to overall identify
biomarkers with within this strategy
other advantages of using imaging
imaging will give us the ability to do
longitudinal studies and this will
directly impact the 3 hours using less
animals so longitudinal studies are
important for a number of scientific
advantages also for impacting the 3
hours typically toxicology studies for
example there's there's many animals
that are sacrificed at
different time points through the study
but using imaging we can push that into
a longitudinal type of analysis which
will enhance the statistics and improve
the consistency of the study throughout
imaging gives us real-time quantifiable
assessments of therapeutic intervention
many of these strategies that we use for
preclinical and in-between are
translatable directly into clinical
trials and they're very powerful at D
risk in Canada drugs using imaging seems
to shorten the time to the clinic and
reduce the cost while maximizing our
biological understanding of the
pathophysiology or therapeutic response
so I hope to impress that imaging also
is a very powerful tool at really
pushing the sophistication of the animal
models that were utilizing so it gives
us direct direct access to the molecular
pathway information and really opens up
the utility of many of these animal
models beyond what traditional use has
demonstrated so using imaging we can get
direct molecular level of
pathophysiology and therapeutic response
and this is the level of the basis that
the disease is actually occurring so we
can do things like monitor gene
expression non-invasively look at target
engagement identify underlying
biological processes of the disease and
direct therapeutic response
so I want to talk a little bit about the
modalities and the functionality of the
modalities and physics behind some of
them it turns out that all imaging
technologies utilize specific
electromagnetic wavelengths to generate
measure signals along that
electromagnetic spectrum to the furthest
rate of the longest wavelength the MRI
magnetic resonance imaging uses radio
frequencies and maintain high static
magnetic field to produce images of high
spatial resolution MRI provides us
anatomical and some physiological data
and it's the signal intensity is
essentially determined by the local
proton density in the relaxation time
constants associated with applying the
radio frequency signal MRI can be
versatile versatile and identifying
tissue contrasts or in some sense some
instances differentiating disease
tissues from normal tissues it gives us
excellent spatial resolution and
temporal resolution particularly for
soft tissues like brain and soft tumors
fluorescence or bioluminescence imaging
optical imaging utilizes the visible or
near visible wavelengths to produce
images of high sensitivity relatively
quickly unfortunately with this modality
spatial resolution lower especially
lower than MRI the in vivo optical
imaging can provide additional
information at the molecular level
looking at target engagement disease
localization for example and it's
relatively easy technology to utilize
but the spatial resolution can be
problematic
x-ray and CT scanning are excellent for
producing anatomical and images of high
sensitivity but we get little molecular
information
and then finally we go to the gamma
radiation type of imaging which is the
positron emission tomography or single
photon emission computed tomography the
pet SPECT which utilize very short
wavelengths in the gamma range of the
spectrum but they provide excellent
sensitivity and yield information about
metabolism molecular targets physiology
and although the spatial resolution may
be better provided by other modalities
other modalities that we are utilizing
for preclinical Imaging include
ultra-high frequency ultrasound these
are designed specifically for
preclinical applications but newer
technologies are coming through for
clinical applicability as well this is
an ultra high frequency ultrasound
system which enables in vivo viewing an
assessment of very small targets
molecular information is gathered
utilizing ultra-high frequency
ultrasound combined with high high
resolution molecular imaging these
systems allow researchers to view small
anatomical structures so we can see
often that the resolution of down to
like 30 microns in real time in a
longitudinal fashion so they're a very
powerful tool that is becoming more and
more popular in preclinical research I
listed here also optical coherence
tomography which is an imaging system
that utilizes optical infer ama tree
it's similar to holography which
produces images internal to tissue micro
structures so you can see superficial
images at a very very high detail very
very good resolution and here we're
looking at the retina as a model of
neurodegeneration and non-invasively we
can get very very high resolution
imaging applications to look at
pathophysiology and therapeutic response
promo endoscopy is also a powerful tool
that we can utilize here's an immunology
example where we have an animal with a
colitis this is a mouse model of colitis
if you look at the top row essentially
this technology utilizes Oh
pardon me I'm on the wrong slide
ah Skippy is a method where we instill
dyes directly into the gastrointestinal
tract at the time of visualization and
using fiber-optic endoscopy and the
purpose of the chroman endoscopy is
chiefly to enhance the characterization
of tissues and look at the functional
physiology of disease
and I'm showing an example of the
utility of thermal endoscopy if you look
at the top row this is after we've
applied methyl and blue dye into the
colon we can see crypt structures which
are associated normal epithelium in the
colon these are not identifiable if you
look at the middle row using light
endoscopy tissues can look normal even
in the presence of colitis lesion
however utilizing the the dye we can
actually take a look at the directly
visualize the crypts structures as a
measure or mark of not only disease but
also of the healing process so it's a
very powerful tool for immunology
applications for example looking at
healing of intestinal mucosa
confocal laser in the microscopy is
another very powerful tool that is new
this is technology that essentially we
can take optical biopsies of tissues in
living animals non-invasively using
laser excitation we can excite
fluorophores whether we target cellular
markers of disease or whether we're
labeling drugs to look at bio
distribution of that from low endoscopy
can be a very powerful way that we can
get level down to the detail of what you
would expect to see histologically the
mainstay of the use currently is
gastrointestinal applications but there
are a number of pulmonary applications
dermatology applications that are coming
online and using the confocal laser
endoscopy we can also identify
vascularity vascular leakage
permeability of the vascularity which
can give us therapeutic response
information for example in intestinal
mucosa colitis lesions are often
associated with vascular leakage and so
we can directly visualize the
vascularity and look at vascular leakage
in a very powerful way using conflict
laser and done microscope
so there are a number of modalities that
I'm not going to go through these are
just some examples of the ones available
each modality has intrinsic intrinsic
advantages and limitations and the idea
is to combine the modalities and exploit
the good characteristics of each of the
modalities and this will help build up
the most cogent and efficient
information package to help design
clinical trials so in this church here
I'm showing that the advantages and
disadvantages of each of the modalities
sensitivity is a key issue and that's
the ability to distinguish your
molecular probe from the background and
some of them as I mentioned the previous
slides are more sensitive than others so
you need to overcome the inherent
limitations of the each individual
modality multimodal approaches are
designed to provide the complimentary
information and combining high
resolution modalities like CT or MRI
with high sensitive techniques will
really continue to broaden the horizon
of research in the drug development
pathway and the slide here I'm showing
some of the facilities imaging
capacities that we have with an MV in
our drug development process where we
have a pet SPECT imaging suite that we
can image non-human primates we can
image rodents and other animals we have
two different magnets 4.7 Tesla and a
seventh Tesla magnet
we have optical imaging capacity
ultrasound ultra-high frequency
ultrasound we are bringing on
photoacoustic tomography we have
confocal laser end of microscopy chromo
endoscopy and we do have a
radiopharmaceutical lab
so I wanted to to the to now walk you
through how imaging techniques can be
applied to the risking new medicines and
the first example that I'm going to show
you is an oncology application and we're
using pet SPECT in this real-life
example to measure target engagement
distribution help identify patients to
select for clinical trials help guide or
dose selection and identify
pharmacodynamic activity so here we have
a chemotherapeutic drug that targets
epithelial growth factor receptor it's
in the her2 family commonly associated
with glioblastoma
it's an antibody based drug in this
example the preclinical imaging process
starts with rodents mice who were
implanted with xenograph tumors of this
glioblastoma and in this example we can
see evaluate the pharmacokinetics of the
uptake in the tumors the tumor is
implanted in the flank so at the half an
hour time frame you can see the the
tracer that's identifying the the tumor
is actually in the urinary system as
it's being excreted about 24 hours you
can see I'll take specific to the tumor
itself and then the optical or the
optimized signal is localizing in the
tumor itself between 72 and 120 168
hours and this will help guide our
understanding as we move through the
preclinical process and into the
clinical application
so within this process the next step was
to ortho topically implant to
glioblastoma and relevant tissue in this
case in the brain and you can see here
at the five-day time point that this
mouse was demonstrating uptake of the
tracer in the specific tumor location of
the tumor in the brain and we can see
the kinetics of that uptake again
signals optimized somewhere between 72
and 120 hours just like it was in the
xenograph model
if we take a look at a patient with a
naturally occurring glioblastoma apply
the same tracer we can see similar
kinetics around day five the signal is
optimized in that patient and we can see
with the whole body image that there are
some some of the metabolic organs will
contain the the tracer itself that the
tumor is localizable visually with the
tracer in the brain at timepoint
so this is a very powerful way that
through our preclinical analysis we can
understand that kinetics of how to
target this tumor we can select patients
that are actually expressing the
molecular target for this tumor and
identify the appropriate kinetics end
and how we expect this drug to engage
this target at what times
you
so in summary does amalga reach the
intended target at vivo it this approach
provides a relatively non-invasive way
to determine target penetration tumor
uptake they're passing the blood-brain
barrier we can clinically validate that
this is a rational approach for patients
who are expressing the molecular target
and pick those patients and this is a
platform where then we can differentiate
candidate drugs in the preclinical
setting before we go into these clinical
trials
you
no selection
Oh
the using imaging will help us guide the
understanding of how the drug is
occupying receptors so receptor
occupancy with PET imaging really
powerful tool and robust tools
established the pivotal relationship
between the dose and the pharmacologic
outcomes without the need to really read
a radial label the drug itself receptor
occupancy studies using PET imaging can
answer critical questions where the drug
has entered the brain engage the target
itself and whether the dose levels
achieve sufficient receptor occupancy
level for the desired effects at the
adequate therapeutic index are we using
the lowest dose that can produce the
best pharmacodynamic response in the way
this is done is to develop or validate a
tracer we do this internally in-house we
can image our animal models
non-invasively using the PET imaging
technique and then we can generate the
exposure exposure receptor occupancy
data and then actually calculate the
receptor occupancy based on the level of
the drug that was dosed in our animal
models and significance and value of
resect receptor occupancy studies can be
summarized really in three ways so
firstly without wasting unifor to label
the drug Canada we can learn whether the
test drug can penetrate the blood-brain
barrier secondly superior to imaging the
the radio label drug itself the receptor
occupancy studies can tell us whether
the director has bound founded our bond
has engaged its target and most
importantly the receptor occupancy curve
provides direct quantitative measurement
of the level of target engagement of the
test drug at a given dose level and this
will provide a bridge for the
pharmacokinetic pharmacodynamic
relationship connecting the drug dose
and the drug efficacy for example when
there's no efficacy
this benefit observe the receptor
occupancy curve can help determine
whether the dose has not been pushed
high enough to reach certain occupancy
levels or if the receptor binding is
simply not effective target for the
disease for example moving on to the
clinical application performed in a very
similar manner to the preclinical
application we synthesized the tracer
for human use the GMP facility the human
patient is imaged non-invasively in a
PET scanner and during the Phase one
clinical trials these are usually
healthy volunteers that are utilized to
prove target engagement and test
hypothesis proof of concept studies and
so if we look at data that was actually
generated in it in a human clinical
trial using dopamine receptor agonist in
this particular case in the humans
generated receptor occupancy curves
which were remarkably similar to the
non-human primate primate studies that
we developed so this gives us a proof of
concept that our animal model is the
rational model to be able to take back
into the preclinical application and
it's an example of retro translation
where we can then have confidence that
our animal model will represent what's
going to happen with receptor engagement
and people and we can take that
non-human primate model and then
differentiate drug drug candidates
knowing that it's an acceptable model
and this provides us with early go/no-go
decisions this is an example of how we
can take this information knowing that
we have a relevant animal model knowing
the receptor occupancy is optimized with
the drug dose and whether we see the
appropriate physiologic response or not
it's a way that that can be captured in
the preclinical phase before going to
especially late clinical phase studies
which are very expensive and time
consuming so
so it's really a way that provides a
relatively non-invasive way to look at
target penetration allows receptor
occupancy understanding and target
exposures gives us greater confidence
that the proof-of-concept or the
hypothesis is actually being tested in
the clinical studies and it really can
impact things at multiple program
programmatic levels and gives us early
go/no-go decisions and moving drug
candidates forward or not even non-ideal
tracers can still be used for decision
making so Canada radiotracers may also
bind to off target proteins that are
usually structurally or functionally
similar to the imaging target and the
selectivity required for suitable
radiotracers not fixed and depends on
the relative densities of the desired
versus off target proteins as well as
the relative rate of the binding of the
radiotracer so selectivity may not be
problematic if the regional distribution
of the arc off target proteins has
little anatomical overlap with the
imaging target so in that way we can
still use non-ideal tracers to to push
the receptor occupancy information
forward and so we utilize these
routinely for CNS neurologic programs
but also for oncology
Imaging is a very powerful tool at
giving us robust pharmacodynamic
activity so this is an immunology
example does engaging the target
actually elicit a relative physiologic
response and so if we look at
Rheumatology rheumatoid arthritis of
course is characterized by massive
inflammation that there's a considerable
amount of synovial andddd angiogenesis
that occurs and we can target the alpha
beta 3 integrand which mediates the
angiogenesis using PET imaging we can do
this non invasively and we can actually
identify the synovial angiogenesis and
so we mark the disease that's a
biomarker of the disease itself and then
look at therapeutic interventions so if
you look at the images of the humans
that underwent PET imaging to the very
right of the slide one of them is
treated with or this is one patient
there's a pretreatment and then you can
see the therapeutic response or the
shrinking of the angiogenesis after this
patient was treated with steroids
imaging is very careful also a very
powerful tool used for safety analysis
for toxicology for de-risking drugs this
will give us a way to look at imaging
gives us a way to look at off target
effects for total body biodistribution
in a very robust way we can tell whether
the effect is reversible or not using
longitudinal studies imaging is very
useful often for developing safety
biomarkers we can use imaging as a means
to calculate organ weight look at tissue
perfusion changes
oxygenation deoxygenation very
sensitively evaluate cardiology
cardiovascular effects using speckle
tracking echocardiography for example
and so there's there's many ways to
address safety imaging program that will
give us information that will extend
beyond typical toxicology studies which
are done by again euthanizing animals on
multiple time points and often many of
these imaging modalities are directly
translatable to clinical protocols so
having a package that you can take to
the FDA demonstrating the ability to
identify adverse effects of a drug and
the preclinical setting can be utilized
to design a rational clinical approach
as well
you
Oh summarize in this particular make in
these particular examples we were able
to powerfully look at target uptake
target engagement select patients select
dose look at the pharmacodynamic
activity and also utilize imaging to
identify safety she's associated with
the drug I wanted to go through another
example
immunology example of a non pet non
SPECT application this is the chromo
endoscopy and again this is looking at
colitis model rodent model and this
inflammation was induced in this
particular model using DSS and we're
looking at the cone of the mouse at
different time points and chromo
endoscopy is powerful at helping us
identify healing characteristics after
therapeutic intervention so the
different columns are representative of
mice that were treated with different
therapeutic interventions and you can
see the presence or absence of crypt
formation depending on how the animal is
responding to the therapeutic
intervention so it gives us a really
powerful tool and allows us to
longitudinally analyze these different
therapeutic responses in this animal
relatively non-invasively we can also
look at vascular permeability as
mentioned before so labeling proton
proteins we can look directly to see if
there's vascular leakage that's
occurring using the confocal laser into
microscope so combining the chromo and
endoscope with the confocal laser endo
microscope gives us a really powerful
way to assess therapeutic intervention
and a highly specific manner compared to
standard histology which is
time-consuming and expensive and
requires biopsies and or hand or
euthanasia and where you lose the
ability to conduct longitudinal studies
i wanted to also impress the idea that
Imaging can really impact the the three
hours of animal use not only can we use
imaging I mentioned we can take optical
biopsies for example so we're not
actually having to remove tissue from a
living animal and this is a way that we
can refine the research the way that
we're using the animal will minimize
pain will minimize distress in a lot of
situations and probably the most
powerful way that it impacts the three
hours is again to give us the ability to
do longitudinal assessments especially
when you're looking at treatment
efficacy again other methods often
require separate groups of animals to be
euthanized so the measurements can be
made for each study at time point in
each treatment group so using the in
vivo imaging because an animal can be
evaluated in multiple time points one
group of animals can be used for all the
time points in each treatment group and
by imaging the animals prior to the
initiation of the treatment each animal
serves as its own control and the
measurements at all time point to the
animal using the imaging not only reduce
the number of animals it also eliminates
the impact of variability between
animals in each time point in their
thereby increasing this to specific
statistical power of the study itself
it's a really powerful way that that we
can impact the three hours
these are all the slides of the head and
I'm happy to be happy to take questions
be happy to take questions
thank you doctor and machi dong for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask the question drop-down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click the send button
well answer as many of your questions as
we have time for let's get started our
first question is how often are pre
clinical imaging strategies translated
for clinical trial application so it's a
great question that the pre clinical
strategies technology continues to
improve at a rapid rate and the
information that we're gathering from
these newer technologies is again very
powerful and robust and companies that
are producing the preclinical equipment
have also realized that for marketing
purposes is advantageous to produce
associated clinical applicable equipment
as well so for example when we discuss
the confocal laser endo microscope there
is actually a clinically approved unit
for that and in our preclinical studies
we're approaching the design of these
studies with the idea in mind to be able
to come up with a clinical protocol that
we can directly translate the
information we're getting in our
preclinical studies to the to the human
clinical trial obviously the relevance
of the animal model itself is important
as we all know mice are not small people
using a translatable animal models
equally important but it seems to be
more and more common that some of these
imaging modalities can be directly
translated into clinical application pet
SPECT CT MRI are all directly
translatable some of the peripheral
technology
are now coming on board where it's
easier to translate them
thank you for that answer our next
question is has application of
translatable preclinical imaging
really impacted attrition and clinical
trials I think the jury's still out on
that again some of these technologies
are relatively new the the whole pre
clinical translational imaging arenas is
coming on board and it does seem to be
it does seem to make remarkable impact
in designing more cogent clinical trials
my take on the early assessment of
moving this technology into clinical
application seems to reduce clinical
attrition but as mentioned at the
beginning of the slide so really the
regardless of the advancement of
technology the efficiency in the drug
discovery development pathway has really
been declining over the last several
decades so this is a this is a great
hope that pre clinical translational
imaging can really impact this pathway
and make some differences in the
clinical attrition I think as we look at
these technologies we need to look at
them as not only a translatable but a
retro translatable tool where we
continue to iterate information from
both the preclinical phase into the
clinical phase and then bring it back to
preclinical and then move it back into
clinical it's not a static linear
approach but it seems to be more of a
dynamic iterative approach
thank you okay we have time for one more
question what is on the horizon for
translational imaging technology and
application that's also a good question
I mean as I mentioned there are a number
of technologies that are advancing very
rapidly and many of these technologies
are now becoming benchtop systems before
it you know required physicists to to
run some of this equipment experts to be
able to process the data and analyze and
interpret the data now many of these
systems are becoming benched happen can
be utilized by people who don't
necessarily have academic expertise in
the area so as a lot of these new tools
come on board we have to develop
packages of data that would support
clinical applicability I'm excited about
the confocal laser and in Indo
microscopy approach as technologies like
that become available really being able
to see very very high resolution images
and combined but multimodal approaches
utilizing traditional like pet SPECT CT
MRI can give us ways to look at disease
processes and therapeutic intervention
that we really haven't been able to
before and so not only will that help
build our basic science understanding
and what's happening but that also
should make clinical trials more
efficient and give us a lot more
information as we move these drugs
forward and into clinical application
I would like to once again thank dr.
Paul Mackey Don for its presentation I
would also like to thank lab boots for
making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through May of 2018 you'll receive an
email from Labyrinth letting you know
when this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
with your colleagues command meds
today's live event that's all for now
thank you for joining us and we hope to
see you again soon goodbye